so today we're gonna build a fort using
a pickaxe a shovel and an axe and we're
gonna sleep in it let's see what happens
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
oh man well my back is screaming but
thanks to Tommy here we got a lot done
we're gonna call it for today and pick
this up tomorrow well it's another day
and I think Tommy gave me strep throat I
feel like crap but we're gonna have fun
anyway
[Music]
come look at this Hillary Knicks take
[Music]
these all black double yellow ring
around his neck but raised buckets last
night and it is cold and rainy today
we're to keep pecking at this
[Music]
oh yeah well the rain turned into snow
be sloshed ten years of practicing law
and five years of editing YouTube videos
has not prepared me physically for this
challenge this entire hole is pretty
much just fractured rock with a little
bit of mud around it it's slow hard
going but we're getting it done there's
a big drop
[Music]
I'm about three to four feet underground
I'm taking the pickaxe and tearing these
rocks apart and I'm finding these little
salamanders in between the cracks of the
rocks I don't even know how they're
getting down here oh I think my my wall
is about to fail here well I've been
banging on this rock forever and I
finally popped it free but I'm kind of
like the dog that caught the car I'm not
quite sure how to get out of the hole
well it's July and I have now been
working on this hole on and off for
about seven months it's been a little
while since I touched it last but one of
the nice things about it is we just
don't really have any collapses so you
can see there you know nothing's caved
in so that gives me a good a good warm
fuzzy that maybe this won't kill us in
our sleep
[Music]
can we start doing the roof yeah I think
we should start doing the roof yay we're
gonna need a lot of strong timber for
the roof so I'm gonna salvage some of
the wood from my primitive smoker
[Music]
yeah this is in our fireplace well I'm
putting the chimney through its paces
just to see if any of the rocks explode
or get any cave-in or anything like that
just kind of want to bake it a little
bit and it is putting out a ton of heat
because basically what I've made is the
Dakota fire hole that you can sleep in
our gig of you gathering sticks okay
make a pile make a pile of sticks right
there okay yeah just lay right there
there you go do you see any sticks where
that's good
oh here's some more sticks
I got forgot I left a bunch of rocks out
here so I'm taking them out and then
check this out he won't bite you oh look
at that he totally climbed out of the
chimney
lots of earthworms Daniel you've been
finding big ones like this there's
another another big old earthworm
well we know where we're coming from
fishing bait
[Music]
[Music]
well it took many many loads of leaves
but we got it pretty well covered let's
go inside and see how much light is
shining through I've got to go through
and plug all of these holes yeah can you
put leaves on the fort yeah yep any
leaves you find throw them right on
there
sticks logs anything all right there we
go I've been picking at this for over a
year now and I think we're ready for our
first test run me and the boys are gonna
camp in this thing and see how it does
it's supposed to get around freezing
tonight one of the things I'm most
curious about on this test run is how
the fireplace works I did a test fire in
it and it seemed to work okay but if you
build a fire for hours an hour to an
hours there's a chance that you might
catch something on fire today is really
wet it's been raining and snowing all
week long it's cold
humidity's hi so this is a good time to
test it out and see and of course we're
gonna have some water and fire
extinguishers handy just in case but if
we're gonna camp in this thing I got to
get a good pile of wood ready to go for
tonight and get all the stuff for the
boys and we're cooked down here start
camping well we got plenty of wood but I
gotta find somewhere to store it because
I need to sleep there so I'm gonna try
stacking the wood up here along the
shelf
and we'll see if that works there we go
got a nice pile of fuel up in here that
should be enough to last us tonight and
I got some smaller stuff and we just
need to get some tinder and we're ready
to go
all right guys kiss your mama goodbye if
we don't survive it'll be your last
chance that's the case we succumb to the
elements make sure you hunger
don't succumb to the elements come home
what do you think the shelters is cool
hey we're playing for at night that's
right to start the fire
I'm gonna use my push this down all
right you ready for some amazing grilled
cheese sandwiches good-looking bread
look at that oh that is good
hey you want to try that it's really hot
you hold it
you you warm there bud tomahawk chops
[Music]
[Music]
that look good that's wheezy like that
guys did you have a great dinner good
well I think I need to put away all this
cooking stuff and get my bed out are you
swinging all right guys we're all ready
for bed you're gonna get snuggled in in
a second
got a massive pile of wood around the
hearth here so I can just reach out of
my sleeping bag and stoke the fire
without having to get out of the bag you
guys excited yeah you warm good I have
no idea what time it is but that's a big
pile of wood laughter that's pretty good
just had to stand up and restock boys
are sleeping great and it's pretty warm
in here
yes here's something well guys this warm
I just rip off my hoodie this this fires
keeping this place pretty warm do you
guys want french toast
you like that chocolate milk got some
pork belly here Nate you having fun
watching Saturday morning shows and
eating pork belly in bed yeah guys you
having a good time it's a few things
that would improve and put a door on it
and there's some holes that I would fill
up a little bit but worked out pretty
well if you liked this video make sure
to click like leave a comment on our
Facebook page since YouTube's disabled
comments so we can't we can't do that
but anyway if you like what you see
click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning thanks for
watching bye nailed it if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boise B channel where we have
hundreds of videos
like this don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that belt button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching